but dad's gonna try and win a therapy
well he hasn't done therapy with me yet
i'm an expert
oh yeah no yeah this
is what it looks like when you resolve
all your issues
uh-huh
look at all those [ __ ] [ __ ]
yes
oh what is that daybreak by calvin klein
yeah you wish
you wish
look at you
you look like you know an actual human
person tight for the surprise come on
surprising him are we oh
i think last time i surprised him he
took a swing at me wonderful
what is it
well oh yes yes it's a uh it's a goo
it's a [ __ ] goo perfect it's
sourdough starter
amazing i thought that you might like to
make something oh great
yeah okay you shouldn't have opened it
okay very thoughtful
it's been great
thank you very much
thank you for having me
i'm happy tonight you are so swell
double the power mom do you want
thank you about it can you hit a ball
yeah
great because i will give you one
million dollars if you hit a home run
this is the best place for him is this
where you would take your father i'm
sorry can the team have some space
please hey hey here's an idea why don't
you worry about the medicine not the
[ __ ] feng shui
[ __ ] you man
you're gonna stop the [ __ ] that you
[ __ ] insane
stop
it
no
we don't do that with deep leaves
especially on older patients well he's
not an older patient dude he just turned
80. but like physically he's like still
in his 70s and he's in great shape you
[ __ ] scary look you hit me i will
[ __ ] you up
[Music]
ah [ __ ] yeah real we need to control the
narrative control the narrative you
probably yell that when you come oh
control the narrative oh control it
control the narrative oh
[ __ ] you
married
you're barred my husband
she's godfather
oh does he um
with the tortoise
yeah [ __ ] yeah of course how is he
he's dead
i don't know i know i remember i suck at
the whole like corporate flirt thing you
know i just
i
like to lube up and [ __ ] you know
okay
okay no he did not fire me he said it
was just gonna take a little longer but
he said that to be nice what i think he
meant to say was that he wished that mom
gave birth to a can opener because at
least then it would be useful something
washed uh something that he's worn maybe
if you find one okay yeah if he's worn
it if his how am i gonna know if it's
worn just smell it okay jesus i just
want something that smells like him okay
i just want that is that enough for you
[Music]
oh come on serious i'm serious as cancer
[ __ ] more serious [ __ ]
money cancer
he's like a thousand percent better
though he's like a bowling rhino high uh
huh yeah uh slow and steady this morning
he put on a sock so
that's right uh this morning he tried to
put on a sock
there are no bad lifeboats vr can be a
lifeboat vr's uh bubble but uh
yeah no bad ideas porn could be a
lifeboat
except that that's a bad lifeboat
you know sometimes you leave the party
and you wonder what everyone's saying
about you
with me it's usually
who's that young han solo and how do i
get his dick in my ass can i suggest
something yeah
can i suggest we all take our shirts off
okay kendall
what are you doing taking my shirt off
that's all
can make him put his shirt on
i don't uh i don't
i don't [ __ ] know sure
[Music]
shirt off
shirt's off shirts off
how about your jacket off
come on man
yeah all right all right
good
that's all let's go
oops
uh grace
okay see this is why you're staying here
doesn't work there are five bathrooms in
this place and you're here like why are
you here like right now i have to fart
and i'm not like i'm physically not
farting because you're here you know you
rehired frank to babysit me
i don't need a babysitter okay
especially when i don't get to [ __ ] uh
um excuse me uh would it be cool because
i have something very secret in my pants
uh would it be okay to show please or is
that a trigger warning jesus roman
you're a walking [ __ ] lawsuit oh
family style well almost like we're a
family princess so we need to have a
talk what talk what talk um i'm not in a
place right now where i can blah uh it's
not you it's blah uh i'll always care
for blah please delete those pics of my
cop and blah blah blah blah blah that
[ __ ] talk okay you want to talk about
that you want to talk about how we only
[ __ ] once every six months [ __ ] you you
got plenty do you want to talk about
that
that's not fun to talk about just did
show up
i'm thankful for all the love roman has
shown to me
and for
never being
selfish or self-centered or egocentric
or neurotic or unfaithful
[Music]
you're welcome
you and kendall are thinking of killing
your dad uh that's a little greek
tragedy yeah oedipus well did i say that
i was going to [ __ ] marsha no
although i definitely would because
she's hot it's like a
like the first stages of an orgy kind of
exciting but also super awkward just um
i just want you know i think i'm going
to reveal to him that you sexually
abused me as a child excuse me yeah you
just would not stop you're one sick
puppy
you just you're the one who kept trying
to [ __ ] me why would you say that stop
saying that you don't really think that
do you no i'm [ __ ] with you
will you [ __ ] me as a baby
can i just say
i never touched roman inappropriately
if he says i did i didn't well glad to
clear that up man you're five minutes
it's okay you look okay you know it'll
be just fast if i take myself
myself
[Music]
wow
funny and cool disagreeing with dad is
not treason
but trying to make one of his biggest
enemies president is kind of a [ __ ] you
good right is it whiskey time shut the
[ __ ] up
greg hey
oh
dude
[ __ ] you i have a reputation i can't
take my crew to watch some art pricks
dance around in [ __ ] bowler hats and
twizzle their mustaches at a time to the
beats who wants to [ __ ] a hobo
what the [ __ ] have you got planned for
me man
no seriously
he's to lock me in a cage what the [ __ ]
no that's a that's a true story
oh wait you're you're pretending that
you don't remember the dog pound are you
tripping yeah it was a game i had to go
climb in this big dog cage in the
kitchen and wait for someone to come
collect me oh yeah well
i don't know it might be three minutes
might be the whole afternoon four years
old if i was eating dog food out of a
cold tin bowl
i know right they should make a [ __ ]
movie this [ __ ] hey tom can i ask you
something do you remember anything about
a dog town from when you were growing up
sure i remember a game you used to play
okay so he didn't used to lock me in the
[ __ ] cage you were the big cage yeah
in your mother's place the laundry room
in shelton tell me thank you he's trying
to gaslight me no you liked it you asked
to be put in that cage
what yeah that was really weird but i
think you enjoyed it
okay so i asked to eat dog food it was
chocolate cake i think
[ __ ] don't pre-rationalize you get
off you eat the shame for dessert
oh lies
oh cause you yeah the lies can't wait
for the big one tomorrow
all right
well these hands aren't gonna [ __ ]
themselves so
i like your girlfriend ro
oh thank you
i met her at a sex party where she was
giving the groom a [ __ ]
you know you're [ __ ] great
thank you
you're not a head [ __ ] or a [ __ ] or a
leech
you say such a pretty thing because this
isn't this isn't a normal relationship
why
well um
for one thing
we never [ __ ]
oh yeah we do no we don't oh come on
yeah we do we've been busy yes
no you like kind of jerked off near me
no want to be disgusting so listen guys
um
i
do have something i need to tell you um
i was at mom's earlier she had me going
through like her papers and stuff
sorting through some [ __ ]
and uh turns out
uh shiv
you're adopted
and
ken you're adopted
and conor is obviously adopted and so
all that shit's coming to me so you can
look out
can i suggest a hug
[Music]
yeah i'm serious why just come on
bring it in you know you want all right
i'm going blood first
here it comes
here we are
oh i just don't want to rock it at my
wedding stop being a kid oh i'm [ __ ] i'm
an adult and i'm important because i
work for a man with glasses is he a jew
by the way oh come on what it's just a
simple friendly slightly racist question
oh right well i'm glad you've been
watching our programs you shouldn't do
that not with your iq
hello me i actually have to go watch a
[ __ ] satellite launch in japan that
i'm actually in charge of that i hold on
that i reorganized for you for you to
[ __ ] carbon neutral to enjoy yeah
[Music]
so
hey yeah how was it uh lunch oh yes yeah
it
well sorry what how did it go he's been
coordinating satellite launch
how did it go uh it uh
great actually it went great yes yeah
this is amazing cool congratulations
thank you thanks it's very exciting go
ahead and get a drink oh yeah
okay welcome tom to the family i don't
feel like i'm losing a sister
i don't feel like i'm gaining a brother
either
i don't feel anything
it's a mental disorder it's called
borderline personality disorder
why is everybody laughing